before I get started into why I get to
talk to you today I definitely have to
ask are is Naked Gun gonna be in your
future is that something that might
actually happen
um yes we're uh waiting on a script
um
but yeah we're hoping that will happen
this year maybe in the summer time you
know oh so this is like a real go
project like something a priority yeah
part of my Studios I think they
approached Seth MacFarlane
he and his team are working on a
script
so yeah we're hoping to go in the
summertime you know I absolutely want
this to happen so fingers crossed
that'll be the end of my career I'd say
you know I think it'll oh no uh I I
think this could be a great one um so
jumping into why I get to talk to you um
what did it mean like this is your 100th
film and uh and what's cool about it is
it gets to be a role like Marlo which is
just you know it's Marlo
um so what did it mean to you to be able
like for the 100th movie to be a
character like this I mean if I go back
to being a child many many years ago in
the north of Ireland and
uh Sunday afternoon watching uh film
Noir I I remember spicely buchart
the big sleep I think it was
and uh I I was
intrigued I couldn't at that age follow
the stories but there was something
magical about it you know shadowy
figures murky Shady characters and stuff
that that really attracted me you know
so to get the chance to play Philip
morwell
you know along with uh Bob Mitchum
Robert Mitchum on my idolized Elliot
Gould and
and book art of courses I feel very
honored you know and to get a chance to
work with Neil Jordan again this is our
fourth film together yeah one of the
things I love about the genre is that
everyone that's on screen you don't know
ultimately they're all Shades of Gray
you just don't know if they're good
they're bad what their ultimate
motivation is so I'm curious for you
when you're reading a script like that
uh what is it like and how much are you
told in advance you know exactly what's
going to happen and how much is Neil
telling you hey or you know William
Monahan saying to you just just read it
well I knew Bill's work from obviously
scorsese's The Departed and he
descriptive to film I was in by the
Crusades called Kingdom of Heaven so and
I I know Bill is a very very top class
fine writer and so when I heard that
Anil is a terrific writer too and he
usually writes and directs his own stuff
but the fact that he and Belmont were
together working on the plot you know
was just too good to be true
and I think from from the original
script that Neo that Bill had done I'm
sure you know it's based on a black guy
Blonde by John bamville uh wonderful
writer Irish and
so I know Neil was into I think Bill had
said it in the 1950s but the novel was
said in the 1950s forgive me
um but Neil wanted to play with the 30s
and and bring Hollywood into it you know
1938-39 you know
um and that's just made the script
very very rich and had lots of levels to
it you know along with the crime aspects
you know well one of the things I think
the film does well is casting people
like uh actors you know in supporting
roles so you really don't know who the
person or people could be that are
pulling strings that's good that's good
isn't it you know uh it's uh and it's I
personally love that scene in a movie
it's like oh I know him from this oh
I've seen her in this and and you're
right so it does raise the anti-thinking
he's the killer no no no maybe she is
maybe they're in League together or
something you know I'm a big fan of Cole
meanie and you got to work with him on
this and I think you're working with him
in the land of saints and sinners uh
yeah I've known column for in theater
days in Ireland over 40 years ago you
know yeah I'm a big fan of his work uh
obviously I'm a fan from Star Trek but
you know he I'm just a really big fan of
his work so can you talk a little bit
about working with him because he's like
he comes across as a very no-nonsense
guy absolutely but
look as I say I've known Colin for over
40 years you know uh or theater days in
Dublin you know
um so I was thrilled on Neil told me he
was going to be cast in the park you
know as the police detective and he's
he's no nonsense but we still
you know between setups we'd share jokes
or we'll talk about someone
in Ireland that we both knew that may
have passed away or is not remarried or
something like that and then you know
the camera's rolling action you know
column just straight into it you know I
love that I love that it's just a lovely
ease and profession wasn't too of course
you know but it's terrific column really
I know that there's two films I believe
you've shot already which is retribution
and in the land of Saint Sinners the
retribution one sounds cool because it's
all in one car uh you know can you talk
about both of those roles and what Drew
you to those projects
um well retribution I'd work with the
producers
um
oh I've done three films together and uh
I'm shooting again in Berlin uh which is
a city I love and
you know I've done trains
uh airplanes it was time to do something
in a car you know so I spent like 95 of
the movie in a car with my two kids in
the back seats you know
uh and of course there's a
uh a bomb under my car seat which I if I
get up move or if the kids could not
move
stand in the movie you know so uh it was
exciting and very interesting to
play
a thriller like that where I'm literally
almost immobile you know
uh it was certainly a challenge
um but yeah it's come on it's some point
this year
uh in the land of saints and sinners
it's uh set we shot it in Donegal
uh with my dear best friend Aaron Hines
um
you may remember from Belfast and
Brazilian other things
like I had to call up problems in it too
um
it's yeah we finished it last year
towards the end of May
um
I think it'll be a good film yeah Robert
Lawrence that I'd worked with before in
a film called The Marksman he directed
it
hit script and uh a bit of action
different sort of action you know set in
Northern Ireland in the 70s you know
when things were very very
challenging I have to wrap with you
there I'm just going to say sir it is a
pleasure to talk with you as always and
I wish nothing but the best thank you
sir thanks Steve